was für ein foto nämlich ein haufen an
medikamenten die ein schwerkranker
corona patient auf der intensivstation
benötigt diesen ganzen haufen pro tag
was ist das schon gegen ein bisschen
impfstoff fragen vor allen dingen ärzte
jetzt sie werben mit genau diesem foto
noch mal eindringlich für die impfung
und wir wollen ihn jetzt diesen ganzen
corona medikamente haufen mal ganz genau
auseinander nehmen erklären das macht
patricia platin mit ein bisschen hilfe
ja ganz genau hier sehen sie diesen
ganzen haufen jeden tag muss das in den
körper eines menschen der mit corona auf
der intensivstation liegt wir wollen uns
diesen haufen medikamente genauer
ansehen kann hat er schon gesagt ich
habe dabei unterstützung und zwar von
doktor martin allwang apotheker und uns
jetzt auch zugeschaltet schönen guten
tag schön frei und sind und uns helfen
diesen riesigen haufen einmal
durchzugehen wir schauen uns das einmal
genauer an sofort ins auge fällt ja das
hier denn das ist etwas was wir alle
kennen da steht nämlich paracetamol
drauf dass all diese
entschuldigung ja de gerne wir wollen
hören von ihnen was das hier eine
irrsinnige menge man kennt das ja ein
bisschen kopfschmerzen hat dass man sich
damals eine kleine tablette nimmt aber
dass die menge die ein mensch braucht
sehr derzeit mit corona auf der
intensivstation liegt herr otto es
ist ein schmerzmittel und es ist es ist
ebenso sie müssen schauen dass die in
pose die sie dem patienten geben da
kommen wir später dazu dieses künstliche
koma wie manche auch sagen das ist
möglichst glatt ist und dazu darf ja
keine schmerzen haben deswegen gibt mehr
gewalt ist paracetamol gegen die
schmerzenden später noch ein zweites
schmerzen bild dazu gegeben das alpha
unternehmen das betrifft die schweiz
verhindert werden problematisch an
paracetamol ist eben das ist ein
bisschen auf was heißt es ist ein
bisschen das kann in großer menge die
leber schädigen
sie haben das zweite angesprochen
alphand an ehe das ist diese ganze menge
hier fünf milligramm frühen hat darauf
diese ganzen pack länder bekommt aber
der patient auf der intensivstation mit
corona am tag als intel was ist das
genau für ein medikament können sie uns
das noch mal erklären das ist ein
medikament das
der wirkweise ähnlich ist wie das x 4
das dämpft den schmerz heiligen dem
gelernt ich habe gesagt schmerzen sehr
schlecht weil man die narkose tief
machen muss und außerdem
außerdem dämpft das noch den atem der
flex der patient wird ja geatmet nicht
selber ein fremdkörper in der luft und
das besser zu tolerieren das ist eine
erwünschte nebenwirkung vom nil aus den
zwei kunden bekommt man das dann schauen
wir weiter auf diesem jahr wirklich
großen haufen an medikamenten die man
nehmen muss jeden tag wenn man mit krone
auf der intensivstation liegt und da das
ja auch besonders ins auge midazolam
steht da drauf herr dr was hat es damit
auf sich das ist auch ein kurz wirkendes
narkotikum der patient wird ja praktisch
in einen der kurse versetzt damit die
beatmung toleriert und sein kreis laufen
sein ganzer stoffwechsel geschont wird
er wird sozusagen als sprache aber jetzt
zurückgefahren
das machen wir weiter schwere
lungenentzündungen bei dem die atmung
nicht mehr ausreichend mit sauerstoff zu
versorgen und das ist eins von zwei
akkus ermitteln was einander gibt
es sind also auch medikament leben
bekommt wenn man dann ins künstliche
koma versetzt wird wie es ja im
schlimmsten fall dann auch passieren
kann das ist alles standardprogramm auf
intensivstationen um patienten über
mehrere tage in narkose zu bringen weil
in der körper nicht mehr in der lage ist
in den organismus bei bewusstsein zu
versorgen lassen sie uns dank herr dr
allwang weiter auf diesem foto noch
einmal spazieren gehen man sieht nämlich
noch allerlei mehr medikamente als die
die wir gerade besprochen haben und zum
beispiel hier hinten gibt es ganz große
flaschen da kann man kinder steht
protein drauf rdr allwang was hat es
damit auf sich ja das ist der patient
kann ja keine nahrung zu sich nehmen
erst einmal diesen tubus im rachen und
zweitens wer nicht bei bewusstsein und
man muss wenn die narkose so lange
dauert ja dafür sagen dass nährstoffen
versorgt das protein ist dasselbe wie
immer ist das ist dasselbe wort es ist
sind zwei nährstoff konzentrate ist auch
noch flüssigkeit hier zu sehen natürlich
gegen ihren arbeiten ja weiter verliert
flüssigkeit die muss man ersetzen man
muss ihnen sozusagen mit dem
lebensnotwendigen versorgen
vielen dank zum abschluss noch was fällt
ihnen hier auf diesem foto jedes also
dem medikament kann man gar nicht denken
aber was fällt ihnen da noch ins auge
medikamente die wichtig sind in einer so
dramatischen lage für den patienten also
was noch wichtig ist zu erwähnen dass
ist dass das konto des dexamethason das
wird gegeben um entzündungen zu
verringern und man hat herausgefunden
dass patienten unter beratung comic
patienten dass die in der bessere
überlebenschance haben wenn sie das
hinkriegen dass es vielleicht in dem
zusammenhang interessant viele patienten
die die angst von medikamenten die haben
die meiste angst vor kortison und da
klicken wir hier schon eine geballte
ladung ab also weil jetzt auch immer das
argument aufgebracht wird was ist es
gegen die impfung sind ja auch leute die
so generell ängstlich sind und wichtig
im leben ist ja dass man vor den
wichtigen dingen angst hat und es
veranschaulicht dieses bild ganz gut und
da nochmals ganz gutes decks damit dass
unser weg sein sie uns einmal wo finden
wir das mal auf diese man muss ja schon
fast sagen wimmelbild der medikamente wo
finden wir hier das kortison
ich muss es nur mal kurz die nächte
sind allerlei medikamente und kleine
gleicht also
schwer zu finden aber sie sagt mir sind
aufhören zu finden es ist auf jeden es
ist auf jeden fall auch ein bekommt ja
und zwar sind diese kleinen ampullen die
den vordergrund stehen die auch nicht so
oft ich abonniert wie wie das protein
das protein ist praktisch das ist so
anders ihr eine ahnung wie es essen ist
dexamethason unter freunden ist schon
eine ordentliche portion das bekommt man
im alltag sonst nicht ab das ist
wirklich intensivstation deluxe herr
doktor anfangen vielen herzlichen dank
dass ihr uns geholfen haben diesen
wirklich beeindruckend zu großen haufen
an medikamenten zu analysieren das also
nochmal zusammengefasst sind die
medikamente die ein mensch pro tag
bekommt wenn er mit corona auf der
intensivstation liegt